[Musique]
vous avez le choix entre deux réponses
maison où vivre encore qu'une car alors
la question est la suivante qu'est ce
qui selon vous représente le mieux la
réussite alors qu'ils votent pour la
maison s'il vous plaît lever la main le
camping car ok j'aurais pensé à la
maison en même temps c'est normal faut
bien reconnaître le camping-car entassés
dans dix mètres carrés
la déco kitsch robert avec son marcel ça
fait pas forcément rêver et en tout cas
c'est parce qu'ils symbolisent le mieux
la réussite
pourtant je vous présente bob bob ses
surnoms que titouan et nora nos deux
enfants ont donné à notre maison
roulante et bob incarne aujourd'hui pour
nous un nouveau départ notre nouveau
mode de vie bref notre réussite alors
l'arrêt ici c'est quoi c'est pas évident
à définir parce que c'est très subjectif
à 18 ans a peut être obtenir son bac ou
son permis à 25 ans signé un cdi à 30
ans fonder une famille et pour d'autres
la réussite c'est d'avoir une belle
voiture ou une maison il ya donc
plusieurs formes de réussite surtout qu
autour de ce concept il ya des préjugés
des idées reçues on est influencé par la
société notre entourage l'éducation
qu'on a reçue la publicité en tout cas
le message est clair il faut réussir
dans la vie est ce qui est fou c'est que
ce conditionnement qui commence très tôt
travaille bien à l'école
c'est pour ton avenir mais passent au
moins ton bac
ces phrases à ses injonctions mal sont
lourdes de sens et elle nous met la
pression
vouloir me faire croire que tout se joue
à l'école comme si ça allait déterminer
notre réussite à l'om site sis à ce
moment ci ça commence à l'école autant
vous le dire tout de suite moi je suis
mal barré dans la vie
je me suis ennuyé pendant des années des
années j'ai redoublé deux fois j'ai eu
mon bac au forceps mais j'ai eu une
chance dans ma jeunesse bateau je me
passionne pour le journalisme et à l'âge
de 12 ans je parle à la radio tous les
dimanches à 18 ans ouais j'ai un peu
changé non à 18 ans alors je suis
toujours lycéens j'ai écrit mes premiers
articles pour le journal ouest france et
à cette période là bas il ya des
réunions parents profs et certains de
mes professeurs nous explique à mes
parents et à moi que je suis en échec
scolaire et par conséquent journalisme
ça ne peut pas être fait pour moi alors
inutile de vous dire ça dû rassurer les
parents mais moi quand j'ai entendu dire
ça le prof je peux pas m'empêcher de
rigoler intérieurement parce que en fait
j'imaginais ses profs chez eux
tranquillement le week-end installés
dans leur canapé autres années au
journal est probablement certains mes
articles sans qu'ils aient la moindre
idée que c'est moi qui les avais écrit
et donc je suis devenu journaliste et
pendant près de vingt ans j'ai travaillé
en presse écrite aux différents titres
puis en télévision pour laquelle j'ai
signé plus d'une cinquantaine de
documentaires moi ce sont des réussites
mais aussi des échecs et plusieurs
changements de trajectoire à 20 ans j'ai
déjà plein d'idées de business mais je
n'ai pas d'argent et personne ne m'en
entourage est entrepreneur alors je mets
mes idées de côté et je poursuis mes
études
pharmacies pour faire plaisir à mes
parents enfin jusque là première année
un deug d'anglais pour apprendre la
langue et voyager et un master pour
enseigner le français aux étrangers mais
il a fallu que j'attende mes 30 ans donc
je me réveille en autodidacte sans
aucune formation dans le commerce
management
je crée une société de soutien scolaire
à domicile ici sur l'île de la réunion
je suis parti de zéro et tout seul j'ai
monté à ma façon au feeling une première
entreprise qui rapidement de vieillesse
ou le marché il ya trois ans françois
m'a rejoint dans cette grande aventure
de l'entrepreneuriat que j'adore parce
qu'on a créés et depuis on gère trois
entreprises
alors avec alexandra on a de belles
carrières professionnelles des bons
revenus nous sommes mariés nous avons
deux beaux enfants en pleine santé et on
a acheté une maison autant dire qu'on
accrochait une à une toutes les cases de
la réussite dicté par la société alors
pourquoi at-on fait partie du club des
80 pour ça tu parles de ces fameux 80%
ses huit français sur dix qui ont moins
une fois au cours de leur vie tu rêves
de changer de vie oui dans cette salle
vous êtes une centaine dont 80% 20 40 60
80 vous un vous tous ici vous vous êtes
déjà posé la question est ce que je
pourrais changer de vie ou des choses
dans ma vie pour ne plus subir et
prétendent à une vie meilleure
alors si ça vous est arrivé je sais pas
pour vous mais pour nous c'était
compliqué un jour de se rendre compte
que heureux et pourtant et bien quelque
chose ne peuvent pas alors on fait quoi
soit on continue c'est qu'il faut
supporter cette période inconfortable
dans laquelle on ne s'éclate plus dans
notre job on court tellement après le
temps qu'on en oublie effort un peu
comme ces hamsters qui court à toute
vitesse dans leurs roues poursuit tête
baissée et on accepte la situation avec
le risque de s'oublier d'être malheureux
dans pire des cas de faire une
dépression
soit on prend conscience qu'on peut
changer les choses qu'on peut prendre le
contrôle alors on s'interroge ou creuse
un peu plus en profondeur au fond de soi
pourquoi voulons-nous changé qu'est ce
qui nous manque c'est quoi le problème
la société nous aurait-elle menti
réussir dans la vie et être heureux
c'est pas forcément liés à l'or à 30 40
50 ans on passe presque tous par des
périodes de doutes et de remises en
question est souvent très souvent même
c'est le travail l'univers professionnel
qui pose problème
je suis
de moins en moins mon job l'entreprise
pour laquelle j'ai tant donné le matin
je pars au boulot à reculons quand c'est
pas avec la boule au ventre les
conditions de travail sont vraiment
satisfaisant mais je me surprends les
accepte et peut-être par peur de perdre
mon job là parce que au fond moi je vous
dis mais qu'est ce que je pourrais bien
faire d'autre je ne sais faire qu'un
seul métier tu l'ancré dans une espèce
de routine métro-boulot-dodo qui n'a
aucun sens et qui ne plaît pas je me
rends compte que ça fait des années et
des années que je fais un métier que
finalement je n'ai pas choisi et que je
n'aime pas quelle que soit la
problématique n'est pas satisfait de sa
situation et on se sent quand même pris
au piège
c'est là alors qu'il faut s'interroger
sur le sens que l'on veut donner à sa
vie
oui ça peut paraître tout simple mais ce
sont ces questions fondamentales qui
convient se poser quand on commence à
prendre un peu de recul quel sens voulez
vous donnez à votre vie qu'est ce qui
vous rend heureux
qu'est ce qui est véritablement chercher
au plus profond de vous ce qui vous
anime ce qui vous donne le sourire des
étoiles dans les yeux ce qui vous fait
vibrer alors concrètement ça peut être
vivre réaliser un rêve d'enfant vivre de
sa passion
aider les autres penser à soi voyage et
la liste est longue et libre à chacun de
définir son projet pour écrire sa
réussite et accéder à son bonheur pour
nous il était important de travailler
moins
parce que nous avons pas vu mes enfants
grandir et on voulait vraiment profiter
nos enfants et puis il est important
aussi de voyager et de vivre un peu
autrement
alors on a pris les choses en main et on
a décidé de redessiner notre vie de
famille notre vie de couple notre vie
professionnelle et tout cela avec un
nouveau rapport au temps au matériel à
l'argent et à la liberté
alors vous êtes certainement en train de
vous dire ils sont bien mignon de ces
deux là c'est plus facile à dire qu'à
faire
oui vous avez raison c'est pas simple de
penser à des changements dans sa vie de
vouloir passer à l'action
les obstacles sont nombreux il faut
d'abord faire face à ses propres peurs
et la peur un côté absurde qui empêche
d'avancer sommes des êtres d'habitude
installé en ce qu'on appelle une zone de
confort on aime la stabilité on a besoin
d'un cadre rassurant alors c'est sûr
quand on sort de cette zone de confort
ou perd des repères des certitudes
je vais vous faire une confidence
aujourd'hui je suis totalement en dehors
de ma zone de confort en la parole
devant vous être sur scène m'exposer
autant il ya quelques mois encore je
vous aurais dit moi faire une conférence
mais même pas en rêve tellement ça me
faisait peur si je vous raconte ça c'est
parce qu'on n'est pas on ne peut pas
imaginer de quoi on est capable
d'un jour à l'autre et puis quand on
surmonte ses peurs et bien c'est là
qu'on grandit qu'on avance et que les
changements peuvent se faire oui ses
propres peurs il faut donc les accepter
et parce que c'est la porte ouverte où
tout est possible au finalm en est la
preuve
il faut donc faire de ces peurs des amis
en revanche la peur des autres c'est pas
souvent simple d'y faire face parce que
en fait nos familles nos proches nos
amis nouvelle évidemment du bien mais
ils ne se projettent pas dans notre vie
il nous rejette ce qui leur pose
problème a eu dans notre démarche
alors nous nous sommes prouvés en tout
la peur des autres il faut s'en
affranchir on a suffisamment à faire
avec nos petits démons alors j'ai une
question
si aujourd'hui vous vouliez faire un
changement dans votre vie qu'est-ce qui
vous empêcherait qu'est-ce qui vous
bloquerez concrètement chose écrite
oui fin mai mme way
d'autres blocages il y en a forcément
l'argent non les enfants la famille le
travail ce sont les principaux freins au
changement sans fait toute une montagne
c'est surtout opposé et accepter de se
mettre un peu en danger nous pour faire
notre changement de vie on a par exemple
relevé le défi de vendre la maison et
tout ce qu'elle contenait
en seulement deux mois pour ne garder
que 130 kg de bagages les enfants il y
en a fait le choix de les déscolarisés
pour leur offrir une éducation
différente
nos entreprises n'a pris le risque de
transformer des sociétés classiques en
société 2.0 moderne est connecté et
l'argent il ya un appel
harry le baisser nos rémunérations de
gagner moins d'argent et où qu'est ce
que vous seriez prêt à faire pour viser
une vie meilleure
qu'est-ce que vous accepteriez de perdre
vous avez peur de manquer demandez vous
plutôt ce que vous allez gagner alors il
ya eu peur il ya aussi cette
problématique du rapport au temps on vit
dans une société où tout va vite on
passe la plus grande partie de notre
temps où travaillent devant la
télévision derrière son ordinateur sur
son téléphone à faire les courses pour
acheter tout et n'importe quoi bref à
consommer et pendant ce temps là et bien
là vie des filles à une vitesse comme on
prend pas le temps pour réfléchir on
oublie se poser les bonnes questions on
accepte les contraintes et les
conditions de vie et de travail
comme si on n'avait pas le choix comme
si on devait seulement subir comme si on
ne pouvait pas faire autrement
à votre avis est-ce qu'il faut attendre
la retraite pour profiter pleinement de
la vie la retraite il faut quand même
reconnaître que l'échéance peut paraître
lointaine voire même incertaine et ça me
fait penser à notre ami stéphane qui à
50 ans à tout plaquer pour partir faire
un tour du monde à vélo pendant au moins
cinq ans et quand son entourage il
disait mais stéphane da 50 ans attend la
retraite tu partiras après sa réponse
était très clair moi si c'est pour
clament ces deux mois après ma retraite
j'attends page partie de sucre alors
nous non plus on n'a pas tendu mais
aujourd'hui on travaille quatre heures
par jour et on dispose notre temps
différemment on a du temps on a du temps
pour rester un endroit aussi longtemps
qu'on le veut parce qu'on se sent bien
on a du temps de dire autre chose à nos
enfants que dépêche-toi on va être en
retard on a du temps pour créer pensé
faire naître de nouveaux projets
personnels et professionnels comme
l'écriture d'un bouquin ou de formation
sur changement de 10 et surtout on a du
temps pour vivre avec françois nous
croyons profondément que pour atteindre
son erp ou un idéal de vie
il faut croire en soi et aller au bout
de sa démarche même si le chemin est
tortueux même si ça peut prendre du
temps et surtout je veux pas nourrir de
regrets on n'a qu'une vie
je vais vous raconter une histoire guen
c'est une infirmière australienne qui a
passé toute sa vie aux côtés de malades
en soins palliatifs
elle a créé des liens forts avec
certains grands stocks et un jour elle a
commencé à interroger ces personnes en
fin de vie
pour connaître leurs principaux regrets
en voici trois j'aurais aimé avoir eu le
courage de vivre la vie que je voulais
vraiment à celle que les autres à
d'andenne moi j'aurais dû travailler moi
j'aurais aimé me laisser le droit d'être
heureux
alors nous on voulait pas attendre pour
profiter pleinement de la vie être
heureux donc on a trouvé la meilleure
équation aussi dans ce travail et vie de
famille et notre solution c'est donc bob
notre maison roulante avec laquelle nous
parcourons mon de genlis après l'espagne
le portugal la france le maroc dans deux
jours nous quittons la réunion direction
l'amérique du sud
d'ailleurs bob a traversé tout seul
comme un grand l'océan atlantique et
nous attend déjà à montevideo en uruguay
en fait la loupe des quarante ans on a
compris quelque chose d'essentiel fait
une quantité d'un amalgame au mélange
réussite vie accomplie bonheur réussir
dans la vie
c'est satisfaire au conformisme et pour
nos attentes de la société
cochez les fameuses cases alors que
réussir sa vie répond à une quête toute
personnelle alors il faut absolument se
libérer de toutes ces chaînes de ce
conditionnement pour être soi même et
faire ce qu'on a envie
tout à l'heure je vous disais que bob
incarne notre réussite ça peut paraître
bizarre mais pourquoi on vous a dit ça
c'est tout simplement parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous deux mais aussi nos
deux enfants nous sommes libres et
heureux comme jamais nous l'avons été
auparavant ce qu'on a vraiment envie de
partager avec vous aujourd'hui c'est
cette idée que tout le monde peut
dessiner sa vie écrire sa réussite et le
bonheur qui va avec et lieu même on peut
redessiner sa vie autant de fois qu'on
le veut on le ressent le besoin
il n'y a pas qu'un seul schéma nous
aujourd'hui on peut dire qu'on a réussi
notre
vie parce qu'on a trouvé notre bob et
nous sommes convaincus qu'on a tous un
baume qui sommeille en nous merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]